This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
Statements in this program have not been
evaluated by the FDA. As an empowered
individual, you do have options
available. who are honored to continue
and share the teachings of
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
have a founding father of the science of
epigenetics guiding us with the best
options to obtain or maintain optimal
health. Dr. Joel Wallace.
All right. Hello everybody. Let's go
ahead and open up that Zoom room. And
hello and welcome to Daily with Doc and
Becca. My name is Becca Dukes and it is
officially pharmacist Fridays. I am
super excited as we are going to be
bringing another episode that empowers,
educates, elevates, and most important
importantly
helps you make the U-turns needed with
information that you can put in your
toolbox. Well, since it is pharmacist
Fridays, we have the one and only
pharmacist Ben Fuches, who is nationally
known, internationally
>> internationally known. He had the Bright
Side Ben show for a decade,
>> for over a decade,
>> a long time. um and he has been teaching
about the importance of nutrition and
feeding your body from the inside out as
he also is a skin specialist. So folks
help me welcome to the screen and before
he says anything because we are a
resource for an amazing community. If
somebody shared this program with you
make sure that you get back with them.
They cared enough about you to share
this program. So care enough about them
to say thank you and they will be your
first point of contact if you have any
questions in regards to today's show.
Well, today's show
is Ben Fuches live because your body
deserves better answers, folks. So,
pharmacist Ben, welcome to Daily with
Doc and Becca. How are you today?
>> Thank you so much. Oh my goodness. You
didn't tell me my camera's off yet. See
that real quick? Okay.
>> It's all gonna be great.
>> As long you're not.
>> That might be better. No, that's worse.
>> No.
You just carry on. I'll get better.
>> Oh, you're spotlighted. So, everybody in
the world sees you right now. Folks,
this program this program is being
sponsored by Dailywithdoc.com
um where we have good foods bad foods
list articles that help empower you with
more knowledge and also a store with our
number one choice when it comes to
feeding your body intentionally the
nutrients that your body would design to
thrive on. So
with that,
thank you so much for joining us and
providing this education
show.
>> Educational show. Yes, ma'am.
>> This educational show. Yes.
>> You know, I was going to do your
favorite disclaimer, but
>> No, no, no. Isn't it recorded? You
already have it recorded. And I know you
have to do it. I just I just give you a
hard time because it always strikes me
as kind of like shrinking us,
marginalizing us, making us less
important than we really are. You know,
it's it's interesting because there are
certain things that the medical model is
very good at, surgical procedures and
and heroic medicine, as we say, dealing
with trauma, but there really isn't
anything in their wheelhouse for dealing
with most of the things that we most of
the health challenges that we face. They
just don't have the tools. And that's
because all medicine can do is shut
things down, suppress, inhibit, block,
remove. Um they can they can only turn
things off. Basically,
health challenges
require for true healing to turn things
on, not to turn things off. Turning
things off is easy. You shut it down
with poison. You basically just poison
it or you extract it or you electrofeed
it or you radiate it. Making things
happen is a much taller order for the
medical model, but it's not a taller
order for God, nature, the divine force,
the intelligence in the human body. But
we've been so
diminished and we've come to believe
that we're so incompetent
and unable to address our own needs. And
this is true throughout whenever there's
institutionalization,
government and law and medicine.
We become infantilized.
We become dependent. We suffer from
something called learned helplessness.
We learn that we're helpless. We learn
that we're impotent. How do we learn
that? Because we're conditioned to
believe it. We're programmed to believe
it. that there's forces at play that are
bigger than us, viral and parasitic and
bacterial and and cancer and all of
these things that we we we shake in our
boots and quake in our boots about
because we believe we're not capable of
doing it. This the most important
message that we have here is not about
nutrition and it's not about health.
They're part of it of course that's not
the most important message. The most
important message here is about
empowerments.
>> Taking our power back from an
institution that could care less about
us as individuals. And this is the
nature of institutions. Inst. It's
always the institution versus the
individual. Institution comes from the
word or the root of the word institution
is stit institution. What does stit
mean? Static. It stays the same.
Institutions stay the same. Institutions
don't die. Institutions don't have heart
attacks. Institutions don't get sick.
Institutions don't have children.
Institutions don't have families to care
about. Institutions don't have the same
needs and desires as uh as human beings,
as individuals. And so, the needs of an
institution are not the same as the
needs of the individual. And if we
depend on an institution to meet our
needs as an individual, we're barking up
the wrong tree. And uh we don't have if
if we depend on the institution to take
care of us as individuals, we don't have
any right to complain. We're going to
the institution. They're not coming to
us. We're going to the institution. And
so when they extract one of our organs
or poison us with medication or do
whatever they do uh and they don't help
us get better, that's on us. Everybody
out there listening to this program
right now, you have an option. And that
option is to take care of your own
business and we will help you. And
that's one of the beautiful things about
Youngevity. Not that we help with
nutrition. Yes, we do. Not that we help
with nutritional supplements. Yes, that
we do. Not that we help with with uh uh
education information. We help with
empowerment. We help you get your power
back. And if you depend on an
institution, you're barking up the wrong
tree. But if you depend on people like
myself, Dr. Wallik, Rebecca, Marilyn,
AJ, we can help you make a world of
difference. I said help you. You're
going to do it yourself. You're going to
do it, but we're going to help you.
You're going to do the work, but we're
going to help you. And that's why we're
here every Friday and Monday nights.
>> Oh, pharmacist Ben. I'm glad you brought
up Monday night because we already had a
question. Is there going to be
pharmacist Ben bites on Monday?
>> On Monday night? Yeah. Um
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, definitely on Monday night. Friday
we got to talk about I'm not sure we're
doing Friday, but we'll talk about that.
>> Okay. Um but back to your your intro.
>> Yes.
>> You know, they control us with fear.
>> Yes. Well, what is fear? False evidence
appearing real.
Yes.
>> What's the opposite of fear? There's
only according to according to
psychiatrist or psychologists, there's
only two emotions. Fear being one.
What's the other one?
>> Joy.
>> Close. Love.
>> Love.
>> That's literal. That's literal because
fear separates.
>> Here's us against them. Whenever you're
afraid of something, you've created a
separation. Love is the attractive
force. Love is not some airy fairy kind
of emotion,
you know, new age feeling. Love is
literally things coming together.
Gravity is love. When two pieces when
two drops of water are on a windshield,
you'll notice they all want they always
want to go together. Love reduces
surface tension. So everything always
wants to come together. Fear separates.
Love brings everything together. And
yes, they want us in fear. But the
opposite of fear or the antidote to fear
um or what's underneath fear because
fear is fake. What's real underneath
fear is love. Love of the body, love of
God, love of each other, love of
yourself. And that's really the
solution. And when we talk about
nutritional supplementation, you know
what we're talking about? Loving
yourself. When we talk about eating good
foods and not eating the 10 bad foods,
what are we talking about? Loving
yourself. When we talk about breathing
correctly, when we talk about all the
health strategies we talk about, what
are we talking about? Loving yourself.
Love is the attractive force. It pulls
things together. It makes things whole.
The word health comes from the word
whole. Health and whole come from the
same place. Disease is fragmentation.
Disease is when we're separated out.
We're fragmented. What does the medical
model do? fragments us. It focuses on
the heart and it focuses on the liver
and it focuses on the stomach and the
spleen and the brain. And you have a
skin problem, you go to the skin doctor.
You got a a reproductive problem, you go
to the OB/GYN. You got a heart problem,
you go to the cardiologist. And they
separate all of these things into
individual components, which doesn't
work. They fragment us. Health is about
pulling everything together and
recognizing the whole. And the body's a
whole. And that's why we talk about the
great systems. Why do we talk about the
blood? What does the blood do? It
connects everything. It pulls everything
together. And that's why all disease
cannot help but involve the blood. In
fact, the blood is the source of all
chronic degenerative disease because
that's the unifying force. And to
correct it, you correct the blood. And
when you correct the blood, you not only
help the thyroid or the skin or the
digest, whatever you're working on, you
help everything. And that's the beauty
of this model. When you go to the
cardiologist people, when you go to the
cardiologist for a beta blocker, not
only are you poisoning your body, but
you're only focusing on one part of the
system. When you take vi you use your
healthy um healthy brain heart pack or n
ultimate nasin or ultimate efas or
whatever it is you're using for your
heart you're helping your liver and
you're helping your digestive system and
you're helping your skin and you're
helping your brain as you help your
heart because it's an entire system and
nutritional supplementation recognizes
the body as such as an entire system.
The medical model doesn't do that. It
recognizes each component and it's not
its fault because the medical model was
born in the 15th century or so when we
didn't really understand how systems
work. Systems theory, which is the idea
of systems, how everything's all
connected in a system, how you can't
remove one part without affecting all
the other parts and how one part can't
be focused on without working on all the
other parts. really only began we only
started to understand how the systems
worked from a scientific perspective in
until the n in the 1940s.
So
>> literally 500 years or 400 years post
the modern medical model with systems
theory. So it's not necessarily their
fault but it's time to move on.
Obviously
it doesn't work.
Obviously the medical model doesn't
work. And again I always say this but
And I'll say again, I don't like I have
to talk to people who aren't physicians,
who aren't part of the medical model. I
want a a physician to come on the call.
I want a representative of the medical
model to come on the call so we can talk
to them directly. I always feel like I'm
talking behind their back, but nobody
wants to participate. So, I'm just going
to say it. They cannot help us. If you
have heart disease,
they cannot help you save for the some
kind of surgical procedure that perhaps
is necessary, but they can't restore the
heart back to its healthy functioning.
They can eliminate disease or they can
reduce the symptoms of disease, but they
can't make us healthy. Doesn't matter.
We can do it ourselves and we're going
to help you do it.
But in you know eliminating or turning
turning off poisoning you know when you
suppress the body's natural response to
something
doesn't that just allow the
>> obviously
>> whatever is attacking the body to
continue to attack without you knowing
it.
>> Yes. And that's the classic you know
classic example is hypertension. You
know most high blood pressure doctors
are are are freaked out about
hypertension high blood pressure for
good reason. Um and and if you go to the
doctor, they'll say there's no reason
for it. It's just they call it essential
hypertension. Know we've talked about
this before, but you know, it bears
repeating. Essential means it's just
part of you. Essential tremor is a
tremor that has no reason. Supposedly,
obviously everything has a reason, but
supposedly has no reason. It's an
essential tremor. Essential hypertension
is hypertension has no reason.
Obviously, there's a reason, but their
position is it has no reason. It's
essential. 90 95 97% of hypertensive
cases are essential hypertension. No
reason. Obviously, there's a reason. The
reason is is the brain is turning up the
pressure because oxygen and nutrients
are not getting to the tissues and the
brain reads the tissues. So, the brain
says, "Okay, there's no oxygen coming to
the spleen or the intestine or the the
heart or the brain or whatever. It turns
the dial up on the pressure to get more
blood." But what do we do when we go to
the medical interact with with modern
medicine? We take something that does
the exact opposite of what the body's
trying to do, which is drop the
pressure. That's exactly the opposite of
what the body's trying to do. I talked
to a girl today. She's trying to get
pregnant. She can't get pregnant. She's
got this condition called PCOS. PCOS is
we don't ovulate correctly. And it
follows hormonal changes that are
associated with guess what? Blood sugar.
So what do they do? She wants to get
pregnant. What do they do? They crank
her with hormone with a hormone, a
synthetic hormone, a drug that forces
her body to ovulate. When her body
doesn't want to ovulate, her body is
saying, "I'm not making a baby here. I'm
not ovulating." But she wants to have a
baby. So, they crank her with a a drug
that forces her to ovulate. And she
called she uh texted me today. I'm in
terrible abdominal pain. What do I do? I
just had my my shot yesterday. Now, I'm
in terrible abdominal pain. All right.
So this is what happens when you
override the body's intelligence. And
this comes from not respecting the
body's intelligence and looking at the
human body is inherently flawed. And
that's really how modern medicine looks
at it. They look at it as inherently
flawed. In a way, they're right because
it does appear to be flawed, but it's
not inherently flawed. Its flaws are the
end result of poor lifestyle choices.
And that's what we're here to help
people understand. And the first thing
to do is to believe it. Not to say, "Oh,
Ben and and Rebecca and AJ, they're all
full of baloney." But to believe what
we're saying is true. And I think it's I
think it's a no-brainer. And that's why
I try to make it as simple as I can. But
willingness and belief are the first
thing first thing you have to have if
you're going to proceed down this road.
And in reality, this is really the only
road that you want to proceed down if
you want to be healthy. Because as I
said, there's nothing in the modern
medical models magical bag of tricks
that can restore a degenerative body
back to health.
>> And so I want to I don't want to run out
of I don't want to run out of time,
Becca. So let's let's dive in here and
start taking some questions.
>> Absolutely. So folks, if you are here
live with us and you have a question, go
ahead and raise your hand. We're going
to take as many questions as we possibly
can before the end of the hour. And the
first question, pharmacist Ben, I'm
gonna take myself off because I'm going
to be sharing an image. And folks, um,
if you have a light stomach, you may not
like this, but you know what? We've got
people that need help. So, the first one
here, pharmacist Ben, is coming from
Karen. She says, "I have a question for
today's show. I um I have been battling
cysts on both of my eyes,
>> okay,
>> for quite a while." Okay.
>> I use the super KB. Pretty hard and
heavy.
>> She's using what? Say that again.
>> The super KB. So that's the sup ultimate
super uh KB standing for kidney bladder.
Pretty hard and heavy. I currently
>> bladder. Is that a is that a kit system?
>> Um it is it's a product within the
longevity line for
>> I had heard of that. Is it new?
>> Uh no. It's been around quite a while.
It's got
what is it?
>> Yeah. Super KB.
>> Okay. What is that?
>> And the K and the B are together.
>> What is Do you know off hand?
>> Um, it helps to support with uh kidney
and bladder function.
>> Well, yeah, it's called kidney bladder,
but what is it? But that's okay. I'll
see.
>> It does have some some cranberry in it.
I don't have it up on the screen, but I
>> It's a cranberry thing. Why is she
taking that for the sty in her eye? Does
she say
>> Oh, no. She was taking that pretty hard
and had
>> for kidney issue.
for kidney problem
>> probably.
>> Okay. So KB super Kab super I'm sorry to
interrupt you but super KB is a bunch of
herbs for the kidney or for bladder
actually for bladder infections not for
the kidney for for urinary tract bladder
effects. Correct.
>> So her yeah her coach is saying for
cysts. So
>> hang on.
>> Are those cysts in the kidneys or in the
bladder or related to the eyes still?
No, it's not related to
>> let me cranberry cranberry bilberry and
and horsetail such
>> py no it's a bladder drug ursy those are
all bladder herbs
>> so it's they're not for cysts although
they may she may on the kidneys yes
ma'am
>> she she is taking it simply for the eyes
for the cysts because the people have
said that it's good for cysts no matter
where they are now you you may not
believe And that may not be the right
protocol. That's it's
>> okay. But she's taking it but that's why
she's
>> it's not working. She needs something
else.
>> Of course it's not working because it's
it's not going to help her sister.
>> Okay. And she's been on she's been on
the 90 for
>> Okay. That's that's helpful. So here's
the deal. Okay. Do you know this person
by the way, Nancy?
>> This is Jill. Yes, I do.
>> I'm sorry, Jill. Um you know this
person. Okay, good. So, uh sty on the
eye.
>> It's not a sty. Did you see the picture?
>> I'm looking at it now. It looks like a
sty.
>> You think it's a sty?
>> That's what it looks like. That's what
it looks like from the picture. It looks
like a sty. In the case, it's a growth.
That's just that's just semantics. You
can call it a cyst if you want. You can
call it whatever you want. It's a growth
on the eye. Growths involve estrogen and
insulin. Those are two main main reasons
why tissue grows. real quick and it's
hard, you know, you got to get your mind
around how the body is constructed from
a uh from a a building block point of
view because we look at the skin and
I've been studying skin for 40 years and
sometimes I wonder what do people think
when they see the skin because we always
call the skin an organ but how does it
really how does it seem like an organ?
an organ is bloody and and throbs and
it's gooey and like the heart and the
spleen and the brain, you know, those
are organs and and you kind have a sense
of what an organ is, but the skin
doesn't really look like an organ. So,
you got to take a mental leap to
understand that the skin's organ-like
nature. And when you understand the
skin's organ organ-like nature, it makes
more sense that it's made up of
different components. As it turns out,
the skin is made up of layers, and each
layer has its own characteristic. And
the bottom layers of the skin are where
the livingness is. the top layers
there's no livingness. It's the bottom
layers where there's livingness,
aliveness. The top of the skin is not
alive. And there's a very good reason
for that because it's got to be
protective. The livingness is
underneath. When you have a growth, what
part of the body is being affected? The
livingness or the non-livingness?
Clearly, the livingness. When you have a
growth, something's not moving correct.
They're not growing correctly. So this
is a condition of cells that are not
dividing correctly. Whenever cells don't
divide correctly, whether it's cancer,
which is a classic case, or whether it's
sty or whether it's boils or whether
it's psoriasis or whether it's fibroids
or whatever it is, whenever you have
cells that are producing lots of stuff
because they're not dividing correctly,
you have something interfering
with the way cells divide. The classic
two molecules that are involved in
growths and interference with cells
division
are insulin and estrogen.
Now given the fact that 120 million
Americans
have blood sugar issues and probably a
lot more have insulin issues that we
don't know about because those go tend
to go under the radar. The chances are
pretty good this woman's dealing with an
insulin issue. Now, we can um we can
just assume and that's not a bad
assumption really and just start
treating her that way or we can start
probing a little bit. So, this woman I
I'm only looking at her eyes so I can't
really tell but I'm going to guess she's
in her 50s or somewhere thereabouts.
Correct.
>> Yeah, upper 50s.
>> Okay. So upper 50s said it's almost
impossible for somebody who's living the
standard American lifestyle who's not
completely immersed in the world of
nutrition to not have some kind of
dislycemia or insulin issue. Next to
impossible. So right away you can pretty
much assume that there's going to be a
blood sugar insulin issue. But you can
ask questions. Does she have weight gain
around the middle? That's another
classic.
>> Not really. She's very thin. She's too
too thin. But she has a lot of stress.
>> Hang on. Let me finish.
>> Sorry. So, does she have weight gain
around the mouth? Fine, she doesn't. Is
she thin? Extra thin is another sign of
hyperinsulinemia.
So, ins too much insulin can show up as
weight gain or it can show up as
incredible thinness. They're both signs
of insulin disturbances. Does she have
any any vascular issues? Uh, is she on
any medication? Does she have cravings
for sugar? Does she have hypoglycemia?
You see what I'm saying? You want to
start to probe a little bit to see what
else happens. And and there's another
picture Rebecca's gonna show me that is
the same along the same lines.
Things on the skin are fruits. You
that's the picture. Things on the skin
are fruits.
You have to go to the roots. And in a
way, this is so simple that it's too
simple
because we find ourselves giving
everybody the same answer pretty much
with, you know, there's little twists
and turns, but basically it's the same
answer. And that answer involves very
little um corrective measures. You don't
have to take a lot of corrective
measures to make a difference. So, it
sounds simplistic, but it's not. That's
why I say belief is so important.
Insulin is the ma the most important
multifunctional hormone in the body. It
does so many different things. So by
controlling insulin you can control you
can control a lot of things upstream.
Are you with me here Joe?
>> Yes.
>> And so that's where you want to focus
on. This is a if it happens happens
sometimes skies happen in the eye
occasionally and that's one thing but
this woman looks like it's hap. Can you
put the picture up again Rebecca? Well,
she's had it for months and yeah, the
last time I saw that like they were a
little swollen, too. Like
>> Yeah, this doesn't look This looks
pretty significant. And And she's had it
for months. Does it keep Does she get
new ones all the time?
>> Uh, you know what? That's a good
question. I don't know. But I don't
think so. I don't think they've gone
away, but I remember seeing them. They
had more of a boil look on them. So, to
me, they've improved since I saw them
last, but she says they aren't.
>> If they're boils, then that means
they're starting to get infected.
>> Skies typically aren't aren't
infectious. So I'd be working on her
blood sugar. Now I wouldn't you go to a
doctor if you want to just work on the
sty and we know how you know how failed
that can be. But sometimes cosmetically
on the skin a doctor can improve things
cosmetically with lancing and with uh
some kind of topical uh topical nutrient
or topical antibiotic to accelerate
healing. So she can go that route if she
wants to address it cosmetically. But
this is a shot across the bow especially
if she's extra thin like you said. She
is thin and Karen has a history of
serious eye problems before.
>> This is not an eye problem. This is a
skin problem
>> before she started the 90.
>> This is not an eye problem, Jeff. This
is a skin problem.
>> I hear you. I hear what you're saying
that it's blood sugar. That's actually
surprising to me. But yeah, like I said,
>> this is a skin issue. This is on the
skin. And the skin, it's not unusual.
You know, the skin on the eye is very,
very, very thin. It's the thinnest skin
in the body. So, if there's any
disturbances in what's called
differentiation, which is the fancy way
of saying how cells divide as they're
rising to the top, it's not it's not
unusual that it should happen on the
eye. I'd be working on her blood sugar
first of all. I'd be getting on the
healthy blood sugar pack and I'd be
doing the uh anything that she could do
to reduce her blood sugar from a dietary
perspective like the ketogenic diet,
intermittent fasting, ultimate nasin,
ultimate selenium. I'd be treating this
as a blood sugar condition. That's the
first thing. Now, typically when you
have a blood sugar condition, if you
want to do something else, typically
when you have blood sugar problems, or
even if you don't, but and you're
symptomatic, uh you also have some
issues with gallbladder, bile, uh
intestine. Do you guys understand uh
Jill, I'll use you as a sounding board
because I can't see anybody here, but do
you understand that bile and the
gallbladder play a major major
unappreciated role in blood sugar
control?
>> Yeah, definitely.
>> Yes. Good. Because that put doctors
don't recognize that. Most people don't
recognize that. So, that's another place
to work. These are all wonderful places
that you can work. Healthy blood sugar
pack and if she has digestive issues,
work there.
>> He doesn't. I think that might be
>> okay. I was going to say I was going to
say to you uh interviewing patients
about other symptoms is often health is
often helpful. Uh although sometimes
patients don't really recognize things
as problems. So that's not a that's not
a foolproof strategy, but it can be
helpful. Like if she were to tell you,
oh yeah, I bloat or I have gas or you
know I can't eat certain foods that
things like that or I have a gallbladder
removed. That kind of stuff that can be
helpful too. This is a blood sugar
issue. Treat it as blood treated as a
blood sugar issue I should say. And then
I would be working on digestive health
too that if she's symptomatic there.
>> Okay. And by the way, the same thing for
that other gal Becca skin problems like
show show that other picture there.
Those little bumps. I'm sure that I'm
sure that gal is she on the call by any
chance?
I don't think that she's on the call,
but her coach Marilyn is. So,
>> yes, Marilyn, I'm sure she's completely
non plus. Like, what the heck is going
on, right? And I'm sure she's if she's
going to go to a doctor, she's going to
go to a dermatologist because it's on
the skin, right?
>> It's just what you said. She She has
sugar issues. She She like loves bread.
>> Well, this is all this is all this is
almost a classic case of a sugar
problem, of a blood sugar problem. And I
can't see if there's pigmentation or if
it's her hair, but a lot of times
there'll be pigmentation issues as well.
Looks like there might be some
pigmentation, although I can't tell.
Have you ever seen um pigmentation
that's fuzzy on the neck or under the
arms? Have you ever seen that condition?
It's black almost very dark.
>> Yeah. That's that's a almost a classic
sign of insulin compos. And this isn't
exactly like that, but it reminds me of
that. And that's what I'd be focusing.
Is it same thing with mold? Is that a
issue too? You know, like people say
like you have black mold. They'll say
>> no. Mold is mold. Mold's an infectious.
That's that's an immune system
condition. Although there may be some
blood sugar issue, blood sugar problems
involved, but that's an immune problem.
>> Okay.
>> And mold and fungus fungal infections
are incredibly difficult to to treat
because mold they don't want to die. And
fungus, they do everything not to die.
So, it's almost impossible to kill You
got to use super super super heavy duty
drugs.
>> All right, let's go on to the next
question as we have five hands up right
now.
>> Five hands.
>> And Nancy, what question do you have for
pharmacist Ben today? Plus, I have some
questions that came in through the chat
that do not have hands up. So,
>> Nancy, real quick, what question do you
have today?
>> So, I have Dr. Connor Ways um 20-day
protocol for gut health. I just wanted
to know if I should u do the two or
three day fast before I start that
protocol.
>> You can fast if you can I can't you know
you don't necessarily have have to and
that's more of a Dr. Conway question
because I'm not exactly sure what the
program is but fasting is awesome. If
you can fast for three days that'd be
great. Two great one is even good. And
then when I go when I go back to eating,
should I is there a certain thing I
should introduce each time to
>> if you want to if you want to diagnose a
specific food that you're having problem
with. Yeah. You want to eat just one
food. So say you want to check on beans.
You suspect you may have a problem with
beans. After your fast, just do beans
for a day or for a meal, just do beans.
Say you have a problem with dairy or you
suspect a problem with dairy, just do
dairy or eggs. Same way. You know what
I'm saying? So after you fast, pick one
food that you suspect is a problem and
don't put a bunch of spices on it or or
a bunch of, you know, butter or
something that'll interfere with your
results and just eat that food and see
what happens. And that's what
>> Okay. If I don't suspect anything, just
if I don't suspect,
>> you don't suspect anything. You have no
but you have symptoms, digestive
symptoms?
>> No. Well, other than being fat.
>> No, that's not a digestive thing. I mean
like bloating or gas or constipation or
loose stools or
>> loose I do have I do have that's yeah
that's an indicator
>> I'm sure I have something wrong but I
don't
>> loose stools are caused by a lot of
things but one of the things cause loose
stools is your body trying to eliminate
something and that's why um that's the
most common side effects associated with
drugs with prescription drugs is loose
stools. Uh that's because your body's
trying to eliminate stuff. Another
reason why people have loose stools is
because they have an issue with their
gallbladder or they had a gallbladder
removed. That can also cause issues with
loose stools. Irritants can cu toxic
substances that irritate the intestine
can cause loose stools. So malabsorption
of minerals and nutrients can cause
loose stools. So there's different
things that can cause loose stools. Um
but that's a sign if that does happen
that could be indicate that could
indicate that you're not absorbing
nutrients and that's something you want
to check on. So, I would look for foods
that are associated with loose stools
for sure. Um, you can also
>> Two days on the new food, you say, or
one day?
>> Say again.
>> Two days or one day on the new food?
>> I started.
>> Yeah, one day should be fine.
>> Okay.
>> One day. Thank you.
>> That'll be great. I'll let you know.
>> Thank you.
>> Later.
>> You all right? Thank you so much, Nancy.
And let's go right over to AJ.
>> Pharmacist. Ben, how are you today?
Hello, AJ.
>> Fantastic uh to see you again. Um I have
a woman who contacted me just before the
show started and mentioned that she had
a stroke. She's in the hospital, can't
access her nutrients, and wondering what
she might be able to use in the place of
>> Oh, nutrients. Soups, chicken soup,
um vegetable juice. I don't know. I
don't know if they give in the hospital.
Can she smuggle stuff in or is she just
dependent on hospital food? What what
>> she's she's expecting to to to be out on
Tuesday and then uh start on her
regimen.
>> Yeah. Healthy healthy brain and heart
pack as soon as healthy brain heart as
soon as possible. Um and then like
certain foods like chicken soup,
homemade chicken soup, aloe vera,
vegetable juices,
as much concentrated nutrition um as she
can get into her system. And that's why
soups and juices
they give you concentrated nutrients
that your body doesn't have to work to
absorb.
>> Why were you thinking aloe vera?
>> Aloe vera uh for the heart, aloe vera
for the blood can be there's blood
thinners in all. There's natural blood
thinners in aloe vera. All fucoin Z too.
>> And and then is uh what about uh
nervewise repairative? She do any B
vitamins or No.
>> Yeah, that's the healthy star pack. Um
what what's her what's her symptoms?
What does she have?
>> She just mentioned she had a stroke. I
mean, she literally called right as we
were starting
>> all the healthy brain heart pack stuff.
I'd like to talk to her, but yes,
anything she can do for the for
neurology will help. And that's where
the healthy healthy brain heart pack
come in. The BTT has all the B vitamins
in it. She wants to do extra B vitamins,
she can do something like the Ultimate
Daily with extra B vitamins. Vitamin B1
is probably the mo I don't want to
isolate that because they're all they're
all important, but B1 is especially
important for neurology.
>> Um, okay. I'll see you Monday. There's
plenty of people with questions here. I
guess Becca's gonna ask the ones in the
chat.
>> Okay. Well,
>> thank you, sir.
>> Let's go for it.
>> All right. Thank you so much, AJ. And we
have one question here. So this is
interesting. Pharmacist Ben. It just
>> maybe you can shed some light on it. So
Miriam is writing a month ago someone
she knows had surgery to remove five
feet of dead and dying small intestines.
>> Oh my god.
>> At very clear margins. The surgeon said
there was no way, no explanation or why
the bowel died.
Uh apparently over a period of a few
hours
essential bowel death what might be
caused what what what might have caused
>> well she had to be symptomatic things
things don't just happen like that she
had to be symptomatic so what I would I
can't tell you what caused it but I
would want to know what her symptoms um
what her what other symptoms she is she
on the call
>> um Miriam is the individual is not
>> I want to know I'd want to know what
other you know what what happened along
long lines. Bow necrosis or essential
bowel death. That's not like the medical
term necessarily. Um
it I shouldn't say it's not a medical
term. It's not an explan it's not an
explanatory term. The bowel, you know,
it just died. It could be a lack of
blood flow. It could be some kind of
obstruction. Uh but usually there'd be
some uh there'd be symptoms. It doesn't
just happen. So, I'd want to ask her
what else was going on and not
necessarily just to find out for
curiosity's sake, but so you can solve
the problem so it doesn't progress. You
know, if she has some kind of blockage
going on or what they call eskeeia,
which is disruption in the in the
chemistry of the intestine, intestinal
eskeemia, you want to know that so you
can make corrections so things don't the
problem doesn't get worse. So, I'd want
to talk to her and I'd want to ask her
about other symptoms. It's probably the
best thing to do. In fact,
>> Miriam, do you have additional
information?
>> Uh, yes. This person just woke up at 7
o'clock in the morning with intense
abdominal pain and after year after
hours of no relief, he went to the
emergency room and they diagnosed that
uh part of it had died or that he had a
tw they thought he had a twisted bowel,
but when they went in there, they saw
that part of it was dying and dead. And
the margins were very very clear and
there was no explanation. I mean the
normal explanations are twisted bowel or
blood clot or or scar tissue or a tumor.
None of that
>> clots or anything like that?
>> Nope. Nope. Nope.
>> What was his history previous to this?
>> That'll give you clues because he didn't
just he wasn't perfectly healthy and
then this happened. Something must have
been other things going on, right?
>> Uh well, he has other health problems.
That's Yeah, that's you know that's
that's how you assess these things.
Remember remember my my thing about um
Bob Ross. You ever hear me talking about
Bob Ross and the paintings?
>> No.
>> So So Bob You have Rebecca. So Bob Ross
was a painter. He used to be on TV. He
used to show you how easy it was to
paint. And he was always really amazing
how he would do this because he'd put a
little line in the middle of the
painting and you know it would just look
like a line. And then he put another
line say there's two lines. But then he
put a third line and all of a sudden you
could see a river and then a fourth line
there'd be trees and a fifth line
there'd be horizon and sixth line
there'd be birds and it was just these
little lines he was putting on the
canvas. You know what I'm saying? And as
he was putting lines in the canvas a
picture would emerge and that's how you
do this health thing. You get symptoms
so a picture can emerge. If you just
have one symptom that doesn't tell you
anything.
>> Sty in the eye. Okay, that doesn't tell
me anything. I need to have other
symptoms so I can get a picture of
intestinal necrosis or bowel death. that
doesn't tell me anything. I need I need
to have multiple points, sample points,
data points so picture can emerge. And
that's why I ask you what other health
challenges he has because once I get a
picture of what of what's going on in
his system, now we can start to address
causes. If you just say, "Oh, it just
happened. There's nothing we can do."
You don't know what's going to happen
tomorrow. You follow? We want to, our
mission here is to keep this problem
from getting worse or from additional
issues arising. And without knowing
what's causing these problems, we can't
do anything. That's not the doctor's
job.
>> Their job is to take care of that
necrosis, get it out of there. That's
that's incumbent upon him with our help.
So, I would be asking him about other
health challenges that he's dealing
with. That would be the most important
thing. Not not to make him wrong, make
him bad, pick on him, just so we can
figure out what's going on in the system
Bob Ross style so we can correct the
problem.
>> All right.
>> Okay.
>> Thank you so much for bringing that
question, Miriam. Let's go up to John.
John, go ahead and unmute yourself. And
what question do you have for Pharmacist
Ben today?
>> Yes.
Yes. Hi. Um
>> hi.
>> Um my question is related to to my
spinal cord. I was recently uh diagnosed
with uh degenerative disc disease.
>> Okay.
>> But the L5 and S1
>> as well as bulging disc in the same
area.
>> Okay.
>> Let me just preface that. I had
scoliosis as a child. Okay.
>> Matter of fact,
>> all my kids have scoliosis also.
>> Okay.
>> So, um what is it that I can do?
>> Okay. Gotcha. So scoliosis and
degenerative disc disease what I hear
you say. Okay. Now
>> disc L5
>> the fact that it's L5 is irrelevant
doesn't matter fact what what do you
think the most important word in
degenerative disc disease is. And
there's three words.
>> Well degenerative is
>> you got it buddy. That's all that you
need to know. It's degenerative. You
don't know about the doesn't matter.
It's the disc because guaranteed there's
other parts of you degenerating too.
You're seeing the disc. Degeneration of
the connective tissue, which is the mass
of the body, the connected muscle tissue
is 90% of the body. Degeneration of the
connective tissue doesn't just happen
locally.
It's a blood issue. It's all connected.
So degenerate, you're running a higher
risk for vascular disease because
there's connective tissue in the
vascular in the va in the vessels.
You're running a high risk for wrinkles
because of there's connective tissue uh
in the face. you're at high risk for
osteoporosis and higher risk for for
cancers because cancers depend on
deteriorating connective tissue to
metastasize. So, we want to build your
connective tissue. In order to build
your connective tissue, we got to figure
out why it's broken down, why it's
degenerating. Scoliosis is another
example, by the way, of of deteriorating
connective tissue. So, you were
diagnosed with scoliosis, but is really
a degenerative condition at a young age,
and your kids have it, too. So how old
were you by the way when you had when
you got diagnosed with scoliosis?
>> I was 13 and I eventually had surgery
where they placed a ro
>> scoliosis. Okay. So just for the
listeners, scoliosis is a curvatur is a
an abnormal curvature sideways curvature
of the spine. The spine will appear like
a C or sometimes like an S. Um and
there's again there's nothing doctors
can do for it because it's a
degenerative condition. It's a sign that
your your connective tissue specifically
in the spine is not forming correctly.
It's breaking down. So again, that's the
fruit.
The root is upstream.
Now you I don't know if you've been on a
cause before, but we have something we
call the triangle of disease. The
triangle of disease are the three points
that are always upstream of degenerative
conditions. Degenerative conditions are
always downstream and that's why doctors
can't address it. You got to go upstream
to where they're caused from. They're
always caused by this triad. Now, the
triad, if you haven't heard it before, I
know we haven't talked about for a
little bit, but we we used to talk about
all the time, is the digestive system
and the blood sugar system and the
adrenal glands, or the adrenal thyroid
link. Can't really do much about the
thyroid, but the adrenal glands, you
can. So, three points. Number one is the
digestive system and the intestine. If
you have a condition called leaky gut,
you probably heard of this.
Toxicity is going to enter into the
bloodstream and this is going to inflame
the tissue. Inflammation of tissue as we
talked about earlier is going to change
the way cells grow. It's going to change
the way the tissue develops and it's
going to lead to degenerative
conditions. So you got to work on leaky
gut and that's how do you know if you
have leaky gut? Do you have digestive
symptoms? Bloating, gas, diarrhea,
constipation, you know the whole list
that we talk about all the time. That's
first. Secondly,
when you have leaky gut,
that means you have an intestinal
problem.
An intestinal problem means inflammation
in the intestine.
Inflammation the intestine will make the
cells spread apart and that's where you
get the leaky gut. But it will also
compromise absorption of nutrients.
Which means if you have a condition of
leaky gut that's so significant that now
it's causing your tissue, your
connective tissue to degenerate, the
chances are really good that you're not
absorbing B vitamins, that you're not
absorbing minerals, that you're not
absorbing your fats, that you're not
absorbing your electrolytes, that you're
not absorbing vitamin C. So now you got
this onetwo punch of toxicity
that's leading to inflammatory uh
inflammation at the level of the
connective tissues causing the spine to
degenerate.
And on top of it, now you're starving.
Can you see a problem here? All because
of the intestine. Now, additionally, and
I'm guessing you're probably in your 40s
just by the sound of your voice.
Something like that, correct? 40s, 50s.
>> Uh, I'm 63.
>> Oh, 63. Good for you. So, you sound
good. So, chances are pretty good that
you're dislycemic. Also, that you have
blood sugar issues. That's the second
point on the triangle of disease. So,
while there's nothing, and I'm going to
repeat this, there is nothing nothing
nothing
that you could do for scoliosis
directly,
you can't take a scoliosis pill, you
can't take calcium, you can't take uh
scoliosis nutrition, you can't put a
scoliosis cream on, there's nothing you
can do for the scoliosis. Nothing. Do
you get this, sir? This is really
important. Nothing. But you can go
upstream
and correct the problem where it began.
Does that make sense? And that's what
you get that now the and this is for
your kids. It's especially important for
your kids
>> because if you don't, you're setting
them up for a problem as well. So
chances are pretty good that your kids
are dislycemic that is disturbed have
disturbances in blood sugar or insulin
and they're also dealing with this leaky
gut problem and and uh malabsorption of
nutrients. So this would be important
for all of you. Obviously, we want to
help you, but your kids are even more
important. You know, I don't want to I
don't want to say they're more important
than you, but they're younger.
>> I understand.
>> Okay, you understand what I'm saying?
They're younger. So, you want to nip it
in the bud now. So, do a food diary.
Look for problem foods. We're going to
want to correct any intestinal problems.
You got to you probably you're 63. You
probably know that there's a something
going on experience constipation,
diarrhea, gassy, bloaty, and if you
haven't noticed it and then start to
stabilize the blood sugar in the
meantime because the connective tissue
is global that is the connective tissue
in the face
is uh responds similarly to connective
tissue in the in the in the bone and in
the spine or anywhere else in the in the
gut. By the way, leaky gut is a
connective tissue issue, too. In many
ways, you're going to strengthen the
entire connective tissue system.
>> Okay?
>> And let me add one more thing. There's a
very important reaction, chemical
reaction between sugar and connective
tissue, literally. So, we talked about
blood sugar and insulin chemically,
metabolically. And so keeping your sugar
down and stabilizing insulin,
stabilizing insulin is important
chemically because these will accelerate
or enhance inflammation. So you want to
take care of those. But even literally
mechanically, sugar burns the spine, the
spinal tissue, the connective tissue.
It's called glycation. You may have
heard of this reaction. So working on
blood sugar is also very important,
especially for kids because kids love
sugar. I mean, we all live sugar, but
it's easier for kids to go into this uh
this kind of immerse themselves in a
sugary diet because that's just what
kids do and and marketing is such that
it appeals to kids. So, you really want
to focus on that with your kids. How old
are your kids? The kids that have the
>> My oldest, he's 20. I have one 18. She
just went to college and one 16.
>> Yeah. You don't you want to make sure
they're taking care of themselves now.
Otherwise, they're setting themselves up
for a world of hurt. And as I said, you
know, I kind of went gloss by it, but
it's really important for you to
recognize, sir. What is your name, sir?
By the way,
>> uh John Jennings.
>> It's very important. John, you're at
higher risk for a lot of other
connective tissue deteriorating
problems, including including uh
involving the heart and the blood
vessels. So, you want to really make
sure that you're addressing your
connective tissue concerns. Now, even
though
>> my also had high blood pressure.
>> Well, yeah, that's my doctor also had
high blood pressure.
>> There you go. Now, you know, have you
been on a call before, John?
>> No, it's my first time.
>> Okay, good. So, I'm gonna I know for the
pe for people on the call, they're
probably sick of hearing this, but you
know, it's important and there's also
new people on the call, so I'm going to
say this. I'm explain the whole
mechanism and and John, I always like to
explain mechanisms.
I don't want to just tell you what to
do. I want you to understand what's
happening so you can figure out what to
do with our health. Make sense?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So the main way degeneration
occurs in the body and the scoliosis is
a degenerative condition. The main way
degeneration occurs in the body is
through thick blood, sticky blood,
viscous blood. Doctors call it
hyperccoaguable blood. Blood that's not
moving correctly. The blood is
distributing oxygen. It's distributing
nutrients. It's generating electrical
charges. It's detoxifying. The blood is
obviously extremely important. And the
Bible says the life of the flesh is in
the blood. The blood's everything. Once
the blood becomes sticky,
hypercoagulated,
doesn't move as well.
What does the brain do? The brain is
responsible for controlling all for um
regulating the health of all the organs.
So when the brain reads the spleen, the
intestine, the lungs, the heart, the
brain itself, the skin, it reads all of
these tissues for it at for its health
determining its health status of the
tissues. It will sense
low oxygen.
It says, "Oh my gosh, there's no the
ox." This is the brain talking there.
Oxygen in the spleen is dropping. The
oxygen in the heart is dropping. The
oxygen in the skin is dropping. So you
know what the brain does then? The brain
will turn up the garden hose pressure.
It turns up the pressure. You follow me
on this? Make sense?
>> Yes, sir.
>> Okay. So high blood pressure is a sign
that the blood's not moving correctly
and so the brain is turning up the
pressure to get more pressure to get
more blood to the tissues. Anytime you
have essential hypertension,
you want to consider a blood problem.
>> Now, why is this important for you
specifically?
Because scoliosis
is a sign that the tissue is not getting
nutriated and toxicity is building up.
So, makes perfect sense that high blood
pressure would be associis.
What's more,
it's the same problem.
Leaky gut and blood sugar, which are the
first two points on the triangle of
disease. So, you're not going to get out
of this pickle overnight. You didn't get
it. You're 65 or you're whatever you
said. You're in your 60s. So, you you
didn't get into this pickle overnight.
You're not going to get out of it
overnight, but you can start today.
>> Okay?
>> I would be working on cleaning the
blood. I call it cleaning the blood. And
you clean the blood by stopping the
stream of toxicity that gets into the
blood through a leaky gut. And that
means all the intestinal stuff. And
Youngevity excels at intestinal
products. I'll give you just a sampling.
Fucoy Z, I26,
Ultimate Microbiome,
Daily Digest, Nightly Essence, um,
Ultimate Enzymes. I'm probably missing a
couple here. Collagen Peptides. These
are all in the interests of control of
uh strengthening the the leak
strengthening the intestine to reduce
leaky gut and reducing inflammation in
the intestine so you can absorb
nutrients. Then you want to start using
liquid nutrition. Why liquid? Because
you're going to be compromised a little
in your absorption. Liquids are absorbed
much more readily. So liquid nutrition
beyond tangy tangerine of course your
ultimate classic vegetable juices soups
chicken soup would be ideal for you
because chicken soup is a very has
liquid connective tissue in it that will
help build support the building of your
connective tissue. Um aloe vera as we
mentioned earlier
what other liquids you could do um non
juice things that have molecules in them
that are called polysaccharides.
You may have heard of that term. um aloe
vera and um and uh noni juice and
chicken soup or or bone I call bone soup
with real chicken, not Campbell's
chicken soup, but homemade.
>> What do I do? Um because I haven't eaten
chicken in over 30 years.
>> Okay. You're vegetarian.
>> Fish. I do fish.
>> Fish. Then do fish soup.
>> Fish. Yeah, you can do fish soup, but
make sure you're getting bones and make
sure you're getting the shells. If you
do seafood, make sure you're getting
shrimp shells. Shrimp shells have
wonderful connective tissue building
substances, particularly glucosamin.
>> You can use the shrimp shells in your in
your um seafood soup. Use shrimp shells
and then of course filter out the
shells, but dissolve put the shells in
the water so that when you're boiling
the water, the uh the bone building or
connective tissue building substances
from the shrimp will come out in the
water.
>> Yeah. Okay. That'll be new for me
because I I haven't done that type of
seafood either uh in years.
>> Well, enjoy. It's good. It's great. It's
great longevity food.
>> Mhm.
>> Okay.
>> No, I did start on the tangy tangerine
and some
>> That's awesome. That's awesome. Are you
are you're not the guy that we talked to
a couple days ago on Monday night, did
we? Or a couple Monday.
>> No, this is my first time. I I listened
to Rebecca the last time with Dr. Joel
Wallock.
>> Okay. I will order certain packages for
the healthy bone and joint pack.
>> That's awesome.
>> And a few other things I'm looking at
going ahead and getting too.
>> Well, welcome aboard, John. We are
dedicated to your health. Call anytime.
You can call me or Rebecca or any We're
here to help you.
>> Certainly. Appreciate your help and
thank you so much.
>> Thank you. God bless you, my friend.
>> All right. God bless.
>> Okay.
>> Absolutely. Thank you, John, again. Yes.
Welcome to the family. And Ben, I'm so
glad that you clarified not Campbell's
chicken noodle soup. Not Campbell suit.
No,
>> not Campbell. Well, let's go to the next
question. And Yesina, go ahead and
unmute yourself.
>> Good morning. Um, first- time caller and
first time here also. But my question
is, I am 59 and I have been uh when I
turned 50, I I had severe vertigo. Um,
and I had I have been going doctor to
doctor, specialist to specialist.
they
>> yeah they've been ruling out I don't
have uh fibromyalgia anything else uh
the only thing that my symptoms I'm
post-menopausal so the reason of my call
is to find out what can I do I have um
anxiety um
>> got
>> dry dry eyes dry ears I mean everything
that goes with metal
>> plus
you sound like a disaster oh my god what
are we gonna No, I'm just kidding. Let
me see. This is very easy.
>> And the only I'm sorry, doctor. The only
medication that I do take is high blood
pressure medication 50 milligrams.
>> Which one?
>> Uh Lerna. Lorna, I believe it's got
Lerna. Yeah, that's the only one that I
take.
>> Okay. Okay. So, hang on.
>> My blood
>> Oh, go ahead. I'm sorry. Go ahead.
>> My blood sugars um I I'm at 100, you
know, fasted 102, 103. I control my my
my meals. I cook at home. So the only
thing is I feel very off. I feel I have
headaches.
>> Yeah, we're we're going to fix you up
here. We're going to fix you up. Okay.
So all of the symptoms that you
described,
the vertigo and the headaches. What
else? I for what else you mentioned
here. Um you didn't mention high blood
pressure, but I assume that that's a
problem because you're on the low
sartin. Um
all of these are secondary symptoms.
Okay. We always use and if you you're
first time on the call I'll just you
know at the risk of boring people
repeating myself here. There's fruit and
there's the root.
Fruit is the rotten apple on the tree.
Okay. The root is where the rotten apple
comes from. If you got a rotten apple on
the tree, can you fix it by working on
the rotten apple? No. It's rotten. You
ain't can't can't do anything about the
rotten apple. You're going to rotten
apple doctors and they're looking at the
rotten apple and they can't figure out
what the problem is because they're
looking at the rotten apple and there's
no problem there. That's the symptom.
That's the sign.
The problem is upstream.
And that sounds like it could be really
confusing because you say, "Oh my god,
then now what do I do? All I know is
what I can see. How am I going to go
upstream?" The good news is is it's not
that calm because there's really only
two major points upstream that you got
to concern yourself with and there's a
mediating bridge between those two
points and your symptom. Does that make
sense so far?
You s
>> She may have muted herself.
>> She may mute herself. Okay. Well, I want
I would like to be able to talk to her,
but Okay. I'm just going to go ahead and
say what I want.
>> Yes. Yes, it does make sense. I'm sorry.
I couldn't unmute myself.
>> Okay, no worries. Keep yourself off mute
because I want to talk. So, I want
everybody to understand this is has to
make sense. I do not want to tell you
what to do by assertion. Just do this,
do that. I want to tell you how this
happens. And it's not complicated. We
are all fully capable of understanding
this. It's very simple. You have
symptoms, fruit if you will. In your
case, vertigo, which is miserable for
people don't know. You just do you ever
throw up or is you just total dizziness?
>> I ended up in the emergency room five
times throwing up and
>> throwing up. Yeah.
>> Can you imagine for listeners, Becca,
AJ, you ever have the spins? Can you
imagine having the spins like they don't
go away?
>> Can you imagine?
>> I've had vertigo. It stinks.
>> It is beyond words. Miserable, right?
But you can't do anything about vertigo.
You have because that's the apple. You
got to go back downstream. So, the fact
that you have high blood pressure tells
me there's something going on in your
blood, which you know is a good
assumption. Anyway, the only two places
that you can work and need to work are
your blood sugar system and your
digestive system. Now, at this point,
it may have gone into the third point on
the triangle, which is the adrenal
glands. You may have some adrenal
issues. Did this problem get worse after
menopause
>> or did you Yeah, probably has some
adrenal issues there as well. The
adrenal glands are responsible uh for
controlling blood pressure and when your
blood pressure is not controlled
properly that can lead to to a
dizziness. Do you get does the problem
get worse when you bend down and stand
up?
>> Okay. So those are signs signs that
there's some adrenal involved.
>> So and which is not surprising because
it's been going on for a while. But the
first thing you always want to do in
this triad I call it the triangle of
disease. in this triad of of um of
structures in the body or systems in the
body is the digestive system. And that
involves doing a food diary, looking for
problem foods, uh and then eliminating
those foods and then doing digestive
support. As I was telling John earlier,
we got lots of great supplements for the
digestive system. But first, you want to
see what's going on with foods
specifically. If you're 59, then
probably if you've had a food problem,
you probably had it for a while. So,
you're going to want to look for that.
And then you're going to eliminate those
foods and use the nutri the uh digestive
digestive supplements, dig digestive
nutritional supplements. And then you
want to work on the blood sugar system.
That's the second point on the triangle
of disease. Uh and if you're like most
people at the age of 59, you're going to
have some issues with blood sugar. Now,
you mentioned that your blood sugar is
pretty stable and pretty low, but
that could be because your insulin is
high. We don't know that. So insulin
controls blood blood sugar
and your blood sugar can be normal
secondary to or following
elevated insulin
and elevated insulin itself is a problem
even if your blood sugar is normal.
Doctors do not check for insulin and
there it's very difficult almost
impossible really because insulin is
connected to a lot of other things. So,
they'll check for blood sugar and your
blood sugar is fine, but you may be
hyperinsulinemic and and I wouldn't be
surprised if you were. How was your
menopause, by the way?
>> Um, not good. The menopause.
>> How were your menstrual cycles when you
had periods?
>> No, I don't have any more menstrual
cycles.
>> No, no, I know that. But when you had
periods, when you had men
>> Oh, it was normal. Normal.
>> You had them regularly and they weren't
heavy?
>> Regularly? Yes. I never had them.
>> Why do they check you for fibromyalgia?
>> Um, because of the aches and the pains.
They checked me for any uh like a
disease that and nothing everything was
ruled out.
>> Okay.
>> Nothing came back.
>> Well, it nothing came back in terms of
estrogen and that's what they checked
for. Um but you still likely have
toxicity in the blood. Anytime you have
aches and pains from head to toe
that implicates the blood. Why would
implicate the blood do you think?
Sorry, repeat that again. I was reading
>> aches and pains from head to toe
implicate the blood.
>> I'm not I don't know
>> because the blood goes everywhere.
>> Right.
>> Okay.
>> The blood goes from head to toe. So
immediately whenever and this for
everybody listening to this program now
or in the future
whenever you have a head to toe problem
you immediately know it's a blood issue.
Now in general degenerative conditions
are going to be blood issues but this is
obvious. Even your doctor can see this.
When you have a headtotoe condition is
circulatory.
How does your circulatory system get
messed up? Well if you're injecting
things through your skin in the back
alley. Are you a crack addict? You're
injecting up meth or heroin. No, I'm I'm
teasing you. You say I don't think you
are. Other than that, how do things get
into the bloodstream?
You sia
>> through through liquids. Food.
>> Food. Food. Do you see how you you now
become your own doctor in a common sense
way?
You see got more information in five
minutes from some stranger on the on the
internet than you got in years from
going to doctors.
You have more control of your body right
now because now you see what's
happening.
You've got a blood toxicity issue at
this point. It's probably stressing. You
probably got some adrenal stress. The
fact that you had a bad menopause tells
me that there was definitely some kind
of adrenal issues going on. Uh and then
um the headtotoe pain is involves the
blood. That means blood sugar even
though your blood sugar is normal. Could
be insulin and that means uh digestive
distress. These are all areas that you
can work from the comfort of your own
home without going to any doctor who
can't do anything anyway.
And we'll help you do that. Whoever your
upline is. Do you have an upline? Do you
have somebody you're working with?
>> No, this is my first time.
>> Okay. Now we get all these first- time
people. That's great. So, we're gonna
work with you. If you like, you call AJ
or Becca and they and they they're great
themselves, but they can always plug
into me, too.
>> Okay. This is all all doable, Einia.
This is all fixable.
>> Thank you.
>> And check your me check your chat
messages, Yinia. I put some information
in the chat for you there. Um,
pharmacist Ben, do you have a hard stop?
>> I got a hard stop and I'm late. So, does
that all make sense?
>> Three minutes after. So, we do have
three more questions. do them on Monday.
Get on Monday.
>> On Monday. What time?
>> Uh, we'll do Monday earlier. Uh, let's
do it at 9:00. AJ 9 Eastern.
>> 9 Eastern. Perfect. Perfect. Perfect.
>> God bless you all. And uh, I guess I
won't see you next week or we'll talk
about that. I might be around. No, you
take off.
>> Hey, if you're available,
>> I might be. Depends.
>> Okay, sounds good.
>> You're the man. Promise. Thank you. God
bless everybody.
>> Thank you, Pharmacist Ben. Have a
fantastic weekend and thank you so much
for giving us more information that
empowers us as individuals
>> to make better choices. And how
important is it that we have healthy
blood, folks?
That we not rely on a pharmaceutical
control our blood pressure or our blood
sugar.
It's through nutrition. And that's what
this program is all about is helping you
realize the importance of what you put
in your mouth, as Dr. Judy Reynolds
says, in that pie hole
and how the body itself responds to it.
So folks, if you were listening to this
program and it spoke to you and you've
got more and more questions, give back
with the person. shared this program
with you or if there's no one to thank,
we do have a call team standing by of
certified holistic health coaches at
855-9493377.
Again, that's 855-9493377.
And if you're watching us on any of the
social platforms, make sure that you're
following us. go to our website,
sign up for our email list so that you
get notifications when the program goes
live and information about the
programming and our newsletter.
And for those of you who are
here because somebody cared enough about
you, don't forget to thank them
and ask them questions that they may
that you may have to get more
information. Folks, my name is Becca
Dukes. As a certified holistic health
coach and also a certified naturopathic
practitioner, it is my honor, my mission
to make sure that people get information
that they can do and take control of
their own health.
I myself
was under the control of a system that
pushed me off to pain management after
they couldn't one I refused their
surgeries because I saw what it did with
my aunt and my mother. I didn't want to
go down that road and I am so thankful
that I didn't. So consider the fact that
you saw this program as your sign that
you yourself as an empowered individual
can do more for yourself and your health
journey and U-turns are allowed. Again,
if you have questions or have not spoken
with anybody about this program or any
of the information shared on this
program, you found us on your own, give
us a call at 8559493377.
Pharmacist
Bites on Monday with AJ. Make sure that
you sign up for our newsletter so that
you get more information about that as
well. It is not it is not a live Zoom
but we do live stream to YouTube and
Rumble and where else AJ Facebook
and X.
So for those of you who are on any of
those platforms make sure that you're
following us and have a fantastic
weekend. Oh AJ your hand is up. I'm
sorry.
Um, you know, so we have a lot of new
folks who had questions. Make sure to
tell them where to send the questions,
right?
>> Yep. If you have questions, you can send
questions to questionswithdoc.com.
Again, that's
questionsthedailywithdoc.com.
Anything else?
I I I wanna I just want to say something
to our coaches and our everyday viewers
if you don't mind.
>> Go for it.
>> All right, folks. This is um
the holiday season beginning and next
week a lot of you are going to be around
family. You're going to be next to your
uncle who's had an issue for 30 years.
You're going to be next to your grandma,
be next to your aunt and cousin, and
they're all need help. They don't know
they need help. They don't know where to
go to get that help. But you can help
him. I can remember being at
Thanksgiving helping an uncle who never
listened to me for anything except for
the fact he said, "You look good." He
said, "You don't." He said, "You what
are you doing? I want to know what
you're doing." and I helped them. I'm
telling you folks, this is the time.
This is the opportunity. So, please make
sure you take the bull by the horns and
let folks know that you know how to help
them and do it. Talk to you later.
>> Absolutely. And folks, you know, I have
these co-hosts for a reason.
AJ helping me host when I'm not
available, making sure I don't forget
anything when I am. He also has helped
get us out on all these different
platforms that are reaching you today.
So, I want to do a shout out and thank
you AJ. I also want to thank Marilyn as
she is busy busy in the chat which is
only available here if you're live with
us in the Zoom room. So, thank you so
much, Marilyn, as she's doing dictation
and she's putting additional information
for explanation and how that you can
continue to empower yourself and put
tools in your toolbox for today,
tomorrow for yourself, your family, your
community. And folks, as we're doing
that on the home front,
we're working together around the world
to create a healthier world. And the
last individual on the screen is
actually in South Africa joining us as
he also is a certified holistic health
coach and helping people in his
backyard. And thanks to the internet
and phone apps the way they are, he's
able to help people around the world as
well. So folks, if you've ever thought
of wanting to have your own health and
wellness business or become a health
coach, you can get more information
about the health coaching program
offered by the Institute of Holistic
Health by going to coach.dwithdoc.com.
And
you know, if you've never tried the
products,
I am so thankful I am a product of a
product
because these products were the only
solution after decades of researching.
And I also wish that there was a pill
that had helped me with scoliosis. But
now that my body is neutrified, I no
longer deal with that pain that was
experienced.
um or the pain all over the body like
that F word um that Yinia
was told she had or was checked for. So
everybody, I'm going to stop babbling.
Thank you so much for joining us here
today. Again, my name is Becca Dukes and
as a certified holistic health coach, a
certified naturopathic practitioner and
also the director of student services
for the Institute of Holistic Health and
the producer and host of this show.
You are part of my mission.
Let's make it a successful one by
getting the 90 and you as well. Until
next time, bye for now.
This program is for educational purposes
only. The content is not intended to
diagnose, treat, cure, or prevent any
diseases, nor is it intended to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The statements in this program have not
been evaluated by the FDA. Testimonials
are shared as individual experiences of
the individual. Results vary and may not
be typical. We do not make any claims
regarding health or income. As an
empowered individual, you do have
options available. We are honored to
have a founding father of the science of
epigenetics guiding us with the best
options to obtain or maintain optimal
health. Dr. Joel Wallley.